remember so I'm just going to read the
um
policy okay good evening and welcome to
this Committee of the development
Community I will now read out the
emergency evacuation announcement there
are no planned fire drills so if the
alarm goes off please leave the building
in an orderly fashion through the
nearest fire exit please use either the
Firex sit through the main doors of the
hall off the fire exit in the storeroom
adjacent to the stage the fire assembly
point is the island in front of the main
entrance to the building
please do not delay your evacuate your
evacuations to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silent
please note that toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer members of
the public which there is only one good
evening I reminded that this is an
official meeting and the items before us
will be debated according to the usual
Council rules for Council meetings to
which the public are omitted members of
the public are not permitted to speak at
this meeting unless they have previously
registered to speak with Democratic
services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear the debate
and counselors will be able to make the
uninformed decision can I please also
remind you to be respectful of all those
attending the meeting including other
members of the public counselors and
officers
page two
members is public
why now we haven't got we don't need to
do the last bit about because no one's
going to be recording so yeah that's
handy members you don't need to listen
to me anymore do you
um members there is I need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak and will be unmuted by
officers for you please make sure that
the microphone is directly in front of
your mouth before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands four and
then against recommendations also ask
for a show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting
agendas item 102 apologies for absence
absences and substitutes
we received apologies from absence from
councilors Tracy Knight Bob Milne and
Stuart Wilson
councilor Hawaii will be substituting
for council tonight
agenda three non-members attending there
are none
gender form me uh minutes of the meeting
held on the 28th of March are these
agreed members thank you agenda item
five to receive Declarations of Interest
are there any members
no thank you
did you say so I'm sorry agenda item six
items referred from the weekly list 22
stroke zero one one nine eight stroke
full arterial Road Chelmsford
Road Rayleigh
Mike's strengths will present the
officer's report thank you Mike
this application is to the site to the
former michelin's Farm in The Wider area
can you speak to sorry can you speak
can you speaking Yeah
start again this application is to the
site of the former michelin's Farm we
have the a1245 former a130 there the
London Liverpool Street Southend
Victoria line here and the a127 to the
South
um the site was released from the green
belt in the council's current allocation
plan
and as part of a wider application if we
could see that please for uh Industrial
Development on the balance of the site
but hopefully when it appears in a
moment we'll have the corner here
um if that's just coming the GT1
allocation yeah thank you there you go
um that's just a extract out of the
council's allocation plan members
hopefully be familiar with that while
we're on this image
beg that you hover on that little detail
there because I think the reason we're
here tonight is because of that
rectangle which hopefully I'll explain
as we proceed so we're we're looking at
some development on this site which is
the provision of two bands like sea wall
type Earthen structures that the
applicant
um is is proposing
it's to do with the Redevelopment of the
commercial site and the planning
permission for the balance of that here
we see is to do with the implementation
of this site they can there's a
requirement in both your allocations
plan and the planning consent to
construct these landscaped buns which
we'll see in better detail but just to
get the context of it you've got this
industrial commercial
development hereby
in accord with your allocation but
remember we've got this site here for
Gypsies and travelers as part of the
development overall
and the area that's owned by the
applicants at the current time includes
all of the commercial
and this area that we see in here but
you'll see there's this
Notch out which in your allocation
the line goes through there so they
don't own all they own most but they
don't own all of the allocated site
so they can only submit a planning
application in their ownership for the
buns in as far as they extend onto their
site
if we could see the
um the levels in the bun drainage plan
please here we go in a better detail now
you'll see this is the proposal the
requirements of the allocation would
there be substantial buffers and the
requirements in the planning permission
given is that these should be in the
region of uh 15 meters wide this one the
larger one along the northern Edge
is about 16 to 17 meters mostly except
tapering down to eight meters over here
and this smaller Eastern Bund
in as much as it can't extend onto land
they don't control
that is in the region of 17 to 18 meters
in width but consistent and the access
to the site would come in through this
point here off and through the adjoining
commercial development the buns are
banked at a gradient of one in three
and they would be drained at the base
by a networker those with the Keen Eye
hopefully can see
that takes a perimeter land drain around
the Bund base and then takes it through
a holding tank to hold any surplus back
and then discharge into the drainage
Network at the
one in 100 Year event plus 40 climate
change so if you like the drainage is
squeezed through a small hole
into the drainage Network and then if
there's any surplus that's held back
until such time as the storm abates and
that can still discharge at the at the
reduced right put put very simply
the two buns the northern one is
slightly lower at 2.6 meters down to 1.7
meters in height the Eastern one
slightly higher at 3.3 meters in height
if we could just see the landscape
proposals please here's in better detail
you'll see from the report that they
proposed some trees and I won't go
through all the species but you've seen
them set out in the report trees along
the bun top then uh sporadic shrub
planting in groups different species and
then the most of the cover of the band
is in a meadow grassland with a sort of
strip of domestic Grass at the bottom
presumably for trimming and maintenance
[Applause]
now on the addendum members will see
there's a correction to the analysis in
the officer report page 24. and what
what happened
was when I measured all the site and
everything
I admitted to
count the full allocation I counted what
the applicant had shown as his site so
the conclusion you've got in the report
is that there was a shortfall
because the starting size I made
accidentally smaller
whereas in actual fact you'll see in the
addendum that including the omitted
strip
it comes up to point that the balance of
land that's left to achieve the
allocation that you're looking for meets
the 0.75 of a hectare that is necessary
for 15 plus pitches
and I think that's possibly what's
brought us here tonight is because
without that
so that error
which the applicants identified
now if we can look at the indicative
plan I think that put in members eyes
whether the with the success of this
bonding the site could be achieved
the applicants put together an
indicative plan
yeah in good time
um this isn't for members determination
tonight this is just an indicative plan
to help us with the issue of would the
Buns fit with the uh with the plots and
you'll see that the applicant has drawn
over the bit of land they don't own and
they've also took the opportunity to
extend the band the band before you
tonight is smaller
but they're hopefully showing you
that this this layer also Accords with
government standards for for science
this might not be what ends up on the
site you might come up with something
better or applicants provide something
better but this Accords with government
standards for layout
and you'd come in as circular route
there's 15 plots in the middle of the
site and four extras along the bottom so
you get 19 plots in there
and the access would go through the
estate now this is not for members to
determine by why of an approval or
refusal to give acceptability to this
layout this is just to show that with
the buns in place it is still possible
to meet your allocation
which you'll also see from the
um addendum that then brought up a
debate about whether a condition could
be put on
that would ensure that the Buns would
not compromise
the development of the site that you
want to realize
and you'll see that both officers and
the applicants have had a go at that
to conclude on the officer's point
we could only say that the wording in
the condition would refer to something
like a phrase in the manner which is too
vague for the government's tests on
conditions if you put yourself in the
hands of a developer
building the Buns
without an agreed layout here how would
they know that their buns are not
compromising the layout there has to be
certainty and preciseness
whereas the applicants take a view set
out before you that if actually when you
look at the tests
because it's not necessary in the first
place because you you can see from this
plan that the worries aren't as serious
as perhaps we would have thought without
this they don't believe it provides any
of the tests so
how we could have gone into this with
everybody agreed
is if the applicant was minded to
approve that condition despite its
faults
you could have put that condition on and
then if you had to enforce it later on
the applicants would have signed up to
it see they'd have undermined their
position the applicants don't see that
the condition satisfies the tests
they're not at this stage saying that
they would support it
an office is looking at the tests
themselves find that there is a case on
most of them for acceptability but on
the on the test of preciseness it
wouldn't it be too vague so the
recommendation chairman is approval
without the condition
and as set out before you in the
recommendation in the report
thank you very much
we have one uh public speaker for this
item Mrs de Gardner handsome the
planning agent uh Mr Hanson who's
sitting uh there you've got five minutes
and I'll let you know when you've got
one minute left thank you
is that on yeah
great uh good evening chair and members
of the committee uh my name is Gardner
Hansen I'm from Avison young and here on
behalf of mirastar Investments and we
are the planning Consultants responsible
for the project and for phase two
uh firstly I'd like to say we're very
pleased that planning officers have
recommended this application for
approval tonight
and further we strongly agree with their
assessment related to the substantial
benefits the proposed development will
bring forward to the GT1 site
as you'll be aware of the proposed
development seeks approval for the
formation of landscape funds along both
the northern eastern boundaries of the
GT1 site and has been proposed in order
to address three particular aspects
related to the arterial Park development
so firstly as detailed within tonight's
done report the proposed landscape funds
have been designed specifically to
ensure compliance with the GT1 site
allocation policy
this policy requires minimum of 0.75
hectares to be retained which is the
estimated area required to it to deliver
a minimum of 15 pitches in future as
shown within that indicative site layout
plan
the GT1 policy also requires site
boundary improvements including a
significant vegetated green buffer and
measures that improve separation between
the two sites and the two uses
so many drawings have demonstrated that
the 0.75 hectares the GT1 site will
remain undeveloped and initially we
provided the indicative site layout plan
including access which has been based on
National Gypsy and traveler site design
guidance which demonstrates how these 15
pitches could come forward in future
most landscape funds will also deliver
significant residential immunity
benefits by helping to increase visual
separation between the sites
incorporating high quality landscape
features and importantly assisting and
reducing potential noise transfer
between the two sites
secondly the proposed development has
been designed to meet the requirements
of conditions 10 and 11 of the phase 2
or arterial Park Reserve matters permit
permission contusion condition 10
requires call information that a 20
meter strip along the boundaries is free
from contamination and condition 11
requires a minimum 15 meter green buffer
strip between the two sites
the supporting documents that will be
submitted with the application confirm
the landscape buns would be free from
contamination alongside the high quality
landscape proposals which include a mix
of native trees and shrubs which will
provide the required 15 meter green
buffer between the sites
lastly we'd note by permitting this
development we consider this would
deliver significant local sustainability
benefits by enabling excess soil to
remain on the site
this will
thereby amounts allow for excess soil to
not be transported to local landfills
which will obviously reduce local hgv
traffic on local roads
overall we believe the proposed
landscape bunds will be a great benefit
to all interested parties our client
remains committed to Bringing forward
phase two the arterial Park development
and we trust and hope the committee will
support planning offer officers
recommendation for approval and Glam
Grant permission for proposed
development tonight thank you for your
time thank you Mr Handsome
night and we haven't got Mr Newport
oh well I haven't got you done no
no it's not
no right okay I will take you but I said
and we haven't got cancer in Newport
either
well you can speak on your behalf of
yourself
thank you and then but I will as put you
in for a first place
right yeah five minutes
thank you thank you chairman uh first of
all apologies from councilor no Paul as
you couldn't make this evening and uh
he's
sent his apologies obviously to the
committee as it stands through me
um
first of all
I want to proved this development
there is one
reservation that I've got on this is as
much to
the buns and how they are
stabilized in in a word because
obviously with the amount of rain and
the open space that there is
how do we stabilize those buns for
future reference in in development I'm
sure Mr strengths will give us an answer
on that
um and also is there room
for
an official uh
housing
Hut beer or whatever it be that's going
to be on that side with those that that
particular outlay that you've put
forward thank you
Carlson Stanley can you just for my own
benefit because I didn't understand the
last bit with the hull can you just I'll
sorry I didn't actually understand that
my own benefit obviously it has to be
um governed
the site would have to be governed have
done that administrator there so where
would the administrator be
on that size site office yes that's what
you're asking that's what I'm asking yes
please sorry I should have said site
office but I understand site office I
don't understand sorry okay thank you
Mike strengths would you like to answer
please
you're not on I don't think
thank you
um
this layout as I say is to record with
the design
um submitted by government so I am
familiar with some sites so many sites
having a sort of a central office for
visitors
doctors Medics they report to the site
and perhaps in escorted or shown shown
through this doesn't show one but
remember
this layout is not for your decision
tonight what what it shows is plots
would fit
in the land available
it shows circulation space bin
provisions and sort of visitor parking
Etc there is some spare land down here
for pot plots it may be that you might
substitute one plot up here for a sort
of Visitor Center reception office and
develop one of these the conclusion I
think to be drawn is there's plenty of
room
on the site for a a decent layout
now it wouldn't necessarily be this type
we'd have to wait for that application
to come before you and see if you find
it acceptable but what I think the worry
was leading up to this committee was
particularly on my maths was that the
extent of the Buns
would over dominate the site so that the
actual 15 plus pitches that you've
allocated it for couldn't be achieved
they'd be squeezed out by this and the
applicants responded to that with this
layout looked at the guidance that's
around I don't think there's anything I
could find for Essex as such they've
looked at the national guidance from
government itself applied that in this
typical layout said well look following
that guidance it fits no no problem but
a better layout might be possible when
that comes before you when we get
specialist people
perhaps applying be it County Council
ourselves or somebody else
that take those things in into account I
would say that there are other sites
that perhaps don't have those offices
but it would be down to how it's
designed we want a better site than some
of those you see so hope fields and
places so
um you know it will be down to when that
application is submitted the point being
this application doesn't Prejudice any
of that
these are constructed like
um seawalls
so they put probably clay soil in the
bottoms heavier and then they cap it
with uh topsoil for the growth of the
planting the the grass binds the top
together but I'm sure members will
recall seeing big heavy track layer d8
type excavators that pound that down to
make it stable they roll they roll it
with their tracks They don't necessarily
have a roller behind although sometimes
they do compactors but they they
compress the loose material that's
brought onto the site and they shape it
and then they grade off the sides to the
gradient you want so I've got no qualms
that after a period of time settlement a
lot of the Landscaping scheme you see if
you think of the Landscaping at the end
of the Beltway Hill Road scheme that's
got quite a lot of undulation that was
10 years ago a farmer's flat field
so they've allowed it to stabilize
they've put the right soils on in
structure impacted it and left it alone
to settle and and you know that will be
I think quite a successful space I would
expect the same thing here I mean
there's no planning requirement for how
they engineer it but that's that's what
you would expect that they bring the
material on compact it down layer it and
then finish it off with a decent coat of
topsoil and then plant it after again a
period of settlement
sorry
just a very simple question really
really related but um obviously as this
is Rochford District council's uh Gypsy
and traveler site but the site is
actually owned by the developer who's
going to be responsible for the
maintenance of this area
we're not actually discussing that
tonight and we're actually discussing
these bunks there is a reason being why
because in association with uh councilor
Stanley's concerns obviously if there
are any problems with the buttons is
this something that we are then going to
be looking to the uh developer to
actually maintain going forward if there
are any problems with it thank you
chairman
whilst it was owned by the applicant it
would be their responsibility
and then when they sell the site on or a
quiet compulsory required on whatever
happens it would become the
responsibility of the new owner now what
this application would do would see the
Buns provided in landscape
so it's sitting there waiting for the
next stage and until it changes hand it
would remain the responsibility of this
owner
thank you
um
it's 10 years ago now but the official
position was
this soil will be municipally owned and
run by Essex County Council
does anybody know whether that's still
the same situation I'm just reflecting
to the responsibility idea that's what
was said by the then portfolio holder at
the time in 2013. I can't answer that
okay my
nope
I was just trying to help with this
responsibility thing yeah I think it's
been addressed because if it's sold the
new owner is that's there responsibility
I think Council Council FD sorry
[Music]
thanks chairman
um
this sort of comes down to the 0.75 of a
hectare
where it wasn't included before now it's
included so this makes the site viable
so I really like to go for a vote on
this I suppose because that's what it
really motioned country to approve this
because that's what it really comes down
to is it the right size is it viable and
as far as the officers say it is so I'd
like to put motion through to approve
this
I'll second it thank you all right
members we've got a motion on the table
to approve this application can I have a
show of hands all in favor please
that's unanimous thank you very much I'm
going to now close the meeting at
seven
55. thank you very much members for
attending and thank you Mr Hanson thank
you thank you for all your